من بيروت سينضم الينا العميد الياس حنا
الخبير العسكري والاستراتيجي مرحبا بك
عميد الياس حنا ما الذي يقلق الغرب من ما
يسميه هذه الشراكه الدفاعيه بين ايران
وروسيا
اولا اذا ترسخت ال ال التعاملات بين
الفريقين تصبح عشراكه استراتيجيه تصبح
هناك
نقل المعلومات نقل خبرات وتبادل سلاح وهذا
الامر لا سوف لن يكون فقط للاستعمال
والاستغلال على الساحه الاوكرانيه هناك
ابعاد مختلفه هناك ابعاد في الخليج هناك
ابعاد في همم الهلال الخصيب سوريا العراق
هناك موضوع النووي ماذا سيجري بحقه بلس
وان هناك مساعدات سياسيه والاهم ايضا هناك
التقنيات الحديثه التي قد تعطي لايران
منها السلاح يتم الحديث عن
35 تتحدث عن الطوافات تتحدث عن الصواريخ
الدفاعات الجويه وكل هذه الامور تقوي موقع
ايران ونحن نعرف موقع ايران في الصراع
الاقليمي لقيت المتحده الامريكيه خاصه
واسفائيل طيب همم في موضوع المسيارات عميد
الياس يجري الحديث عن تطوير هذه المسيارات
بين روسيا وايران من جهه وايضا الان لدينا
اتهامات روسيه بان اوكرانيا ايضا تدخل
المسيارات وبدات باستهداف اراضا في داخل
روسيا بها ما هو المشهد المقبل في هذا
الاطار
المشهد المقبل المسيره ال سي هي ارخص اقل
كلفه من كل الاسلحه ليس لها ثمان سياسي
بسيطه على سبيل المثال الشاهد همم 136
يعني الثمن قليل جدا 20.000 دولار يقال
بينما المسيارات الاخرى الغربيه كبيره
كلفه اليوم ما جرى من مسيرات اكرانيه الى
الداخل والعمق الروسي تقول روسيه ان هذه
المسيره ايضا هي من صنع ايام الاتحاد
السوفيتي تم تعديلها لاستعمالها اليوم نحن
في مرحله جديده من استعمال سلاح جديد ليس
لدينا رد حتى الان وليس له هناك تكتيكات
اساسيه وهي اقل كلفه من كل الاسلحه ولكنها
يعني تفعل الضرر وترسل الرسائل بكل
الاتجاهات اذا ترسخت هذا الموضوع في
الصناعات هناك ما يسمى بالتراييل يعني
التجربه والخطا قد تحسن
المسيره الشاهد 136 بتكنولوجيا جديده
بتقدم جديد لتصبح اكثر تطورا وحتى تنافس
المسيرات الغربيه طيب عميد باختصار الان
الدول الغربيه تتواعد بانها لن تسمح بهذه
الشراكه ان تتطور باعتقادك ما الذي يمكن
ان تقوم به
بالحد الادنى هناك العقوبات بالحد الادنى
هناك تدخلات عسكريه
بمكان ما هناك يعني همم الشراكه اصبحت
امرا واقعا اصبحت عمليا مماسسه ال سي
بالحد الادنى همم الرد سياسي بالحد الادنى
الرد بالعقبات ولا نحن نعرف ان العقوبات
يعني اصبحت منذ العام 79 على ايران وحتى
الان لم تاتي بنتائجها التي كانت تتواخها
امريكا اشكرك جزيل الشكر على العميد الياس
عنا الياس حنا الخبير العسكري
والاستراتيجي كنت ضيفنا من بيروت